Robert Pattinson might be running into a
big issue when preparing for the Batman
in a recent YouTube stream beyond the
trailers Grace Randolph disclosed that
sources close to the film's production
are reporting that the actor is having
trouble packing on the necessary pounds
for the role Randolph said I've heard
that Robert Pattinson is having a little
bit of trouble bulking up I think it's
probably impossible for him to fully
bulk up because he just has this light
bill but I think it's hilarious they are
like maybe if we give him a few more
weeks he might bulk up
if he hasn't bulked up by now he's not
going to bulk up just accept you have a
skinny Batman and deal with it we feel
the need to point out a couple of things
here first
Randolph sources are anonymous meaning
that their degree of involvement in the
Batman might be intimately involved or
not involved at all lower or anything in
between
Pattinson hasn't popped up in public at
any point super recently so we have no
idea if he's gotten extremely jacked for
the Batman which is in pre-production
and is thought to be going before the
cameras early next year
second it's worth remembering the role
that Christian Bale played immediately
prior to his debut as the Caped Crusader
and Batman Begins
he appeared is the extremely troubled
physically and psychologically fragile
title character in The Machinist a role
for which he lost enough weight to pose
an actual danger to his health Bale
looked like a skeleton in that movie and
just a year later he was convincingly
playing the big buff Dark Knight now
Balin Pattinson are obviously different
people so it's entirely possible that
the latter could be having some
difficulty packing on the muscle while
the former did not what we're saying is
the fact that Pattinson has a slight
bill doesn't mean anything at all and
there's a strong possibility that his
reported struggle with bulking up is
completely fabricated in fact if you ask
us this report has the suspicious ring
of a rumor floated by parties who don't
think that Pattinson has what it takes
to fill out Batman's cape and cowl will
concede that there isn't much in his
previous filmography to suggest that he
has the type of physical presence
required to portray the Caped Crusader
still if you're mostly familiar with the
actor from his work as sparkly vampire
Edward Cullen in the Twilight series
then you should know that his casting
was no left-field choice because she
believes a lie
camouflage I'm the world's most
dangerous predator Pattinson is a
serious actor as he's demonstrated and
critically acclaimed indie films like
good time and high life since his brush
with franchise fame if you need a higher
profile extremely recent example of his
formidable chops look no further than
the lighthouse the psychological
thriller from director Robert Edgar's is
currently drawing critical acclaim from
across the board and the stark
black-and-white period tale of two
lighthouse keepers slowly driving each
other mad is largely a two-man show
those two men are Pattinson and Willem
Dafoe and if the general critical
consensus is to be believed the younger
actor more than holds his own opposite a
man known far and wide for giving
intense committed performances since
we've gone this far let's edge all the
way out onto our limb here and
suggesting that the most prominent
actors to portray bats in the modern era
Michael Keaton and Tim Burton's films
Bale and Ben Affleck in the early DC
movie universe efforts were hamstrung by
not being the most important characters
in their own movies the Batman as its
title indicates is shaping up to be
Pattinson show even if the flicks
director Matt Reeves builds a tremendous
rogues gallery around him Pattinson has
the opportunity to give us a version of
Batman that would be truly
groundbreaking we'll be able to find out
for sure when the Batman hits screens on
June 25th 2021 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]